Je t'aime tellement
Ka Bedili
je l'ai dans mon coeur
gourou tu ouais
que veux-tu dire ?
des gens méchants
[musique]
Je veux dire
Bien sûr
c'est mon
C'est une chose folle à propos de l'amour
bien sûr, c'est à moi
Êtes-vous fou ou amoureux?
tu le démarres
si reconnu
C'est le tien
des yeux
c'est de ma faute
folie
[musique]
mon cœur est à toi seulement
Mon cœur ne désire que toi
Amour, que tu veuilles venir ou non, nous viendrons
faire
[musique]
attendez-moi
Êtes-vous fou ou amoureux?
Thon Suru
si reconnu
Oh tes yeux
[musique]
faute
ce
l'amour est à toi
aller ou
je t'aime
aller
[musique]
Roha
Un jour, je suis mort étouffé par l'espoir.
nous irons aussi loin que nous voulons
n'appelle plus
Volonté
Est-ce mon amour ou mon amour ?
beau
c'est mon
Est-ce la folie ou l'amour ?
[musique]
de cela
Mon
fou
[musique]
protégé